Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar!
In the following star shaped figure,
what is the measure of angle A in degrees?
This problem appeared on a test given to eighth grade students in 1999.
Approximately 75% of students did not mark the correct answer.
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try, and when your ready keep watching the video for the solution.
One way to solve this problem is by using several geometric principles.
One principle is that a straight line measures 180 degrees.
We can look at the angle next to 100 degrees,
and calculate that  it must be 180 minus 100 or 80 degrees.
Similarly, the angle next to 110 degrees must equal 180 minus 110,
and therefore that angle is equal to 70 degrees.
We now use the principle, that the angles in a triangle sum up to 180 degrees.
In the triangle with 40 degrees and 70 degrees, the final angle will be equal to 180 minus 40 minus 70.
So the final angle of this triangle is 70 degrees.
We then use the principle, that vertical angles have equal measure,
so the angle above 70 degrees is equal to 70 degrees,
and finally we can use the principle that the three angles in a triangle sum to 180 degrees.
This means angle A is equal to 180 minus 80 minus 70.
And therefore angle A is equal to 30 degrees.
So that's our answer: 30 degrees.
There is in fact a quicker way to solve this problem.
You only need to use one principle,
which is that the angles in a triangle sum up to 180 degrees.
The trick is to look at the correct triangles.
First we'll consider the triangle that involves a 40-degree angle and a 100-degree angle.
We know that all three angles add up to 180 degrees.
The third angle therefore will be 180 minus 100 minus 40.
This angle is equal to 40 degrees.
We now consider another triangle, which involves angle A.
The other angles are 110 and 40 degrees.
Therefore angle A will equal 180 minus 110 minus 40.
So we directly get that angle A equals 30 degrees.
And we get to our answer much quicker.
Did you figure out this problem?